hello I love twin town welcome to town
saloon so good thank you for having I'm
here with the Merritt Wayne town
population one and the mayor and wait oh
not population - oh yeah melody baby
melody in the show she is she's got her
own path Meli's credential you did it
you just had your opening night how did
it feel oh I had I just had a really
great time at a blast I had a blast with
everybody on the stage and off the stage
it was great to see familiar faces in
the audience it was a wonderful feeling
and the room is it's just a very
friendly I would say informal space yeah
so I really feel you know like letting
my hair down well we're here in the
Twain town saloon thank you for having
us we're right on the stage we perform
and I love it's that saloon vibe of
course you got that country community
here do you love when you bring the
audience out on the stage because I know
that's part of it
oh yeah it's so fun and you know
especially bringing people on the stage
to dance for blue suede of your boots
Menander it's such a big it's such a
popular dance song in country music and
I love you know I do love holding all of
the company making the most of the
country songs I don't have a lot of
really traditional country songs in my
music so songs like who's about if it
meets banana at any amount of mine and I
named home I make the most of it and
really milk the the country vibe so I
gotta ask you
we're here in a saloon after your
opening night how hard did everybody go
out and celebrate oh are you feeling it
this morning at all I'm feeling it
you have to you killed it I was seeing
everybody on Instagram all your fans
loved it you you did amazing I got ask
you some by the numbers how many
costumes
I think there's eight I haven't counted
that's a good question I've got yeah I
think there's eight how many sequins
over half but millions literally secret
oh you mean like how many literally oh
yeah probably in the millions yeah how
many hairstyles just one I did do know I
did too
yeah yeah how many hot guy dancers oh
eight hot guy dancers did they were
those whether they feel the stage my oh
my god and those we got them with the
best we have the whole thing oh no I did
I wanted him you know make sure that
they could get out there and shake their
things guys you know how many pairs of
boots well they have one pair of boots
only for the country section me I've got
like I don't know four or five the quick
changes happen in this show it's Vegas
you're giving them the razzle-dazzle how
do you change so quickly what are the
secret it's a whole it's a whole
choreography about there so there are
four of us you know three girls myself
and it's a very timed choreographed
process it's very much like what goes on
out here also getting to the quick
change is choreography you're running in
heels we need to rehearse the roots the
the lighting where the cables are who is
there the traffic it's it's just
choreographed in order to make it in
time everything's ought to be very
precise the order of which things come
off the order of which things to go on
and if things go wrong I don't make it I
get that tights
well we don't want a wardrobe
malfunction either it's no no no I think
we'll proof on that what makes you
foolproof what's this I don't want to
know what's the secret to no wardrobe
malfunctions it's called a wardrobe
builder and the instructor that knows
what they're doing
Glenda Conway she's like the bass you
need a human yeah like these are not
these aren't
this vision it's not wardrobe to her in
that sense they are there like set
pieces you know they have to have the
right hardware and be designed she knows
how to design all of that when I know
you're so involved too and they're so
beautiful the draping and the sequins do
you have one that you're particularly
proud of for this one one I'm involved
with the styling and of course the
direction of the whole styling and the
looks and then of course I will go to
Glendon say will this fabric hold up are
you gonna be able to wash it every night
I have to be practical yeah so but the
the beauty and the way things move the
colors the the silhouettes are all this
is all something that I conjure up long
before we get into constructing them
well if it's conjured up by you we love
it that you and put so much creativity
in the show I know that you do
everything from designing the costumes
talking about it all how did it feel for
you to literally take the step out on
the stage of your Las Vegas residency
the first night what went through you oh
yeah it's great to see it all coming
together
you know the whole vision every
department that I work with is
passionate and dedicated to what they do
they take direction well they they have
all got great suggestions it's really
about having a great team and but the
fun part for me I mean I like to be on
stage but I'm not watching the show when
I'm on stage so I I don't really get to
enjoy that element I can see the fans
enjoying it but I really do take a lot
of pleasure in designing and developing
the whole look and feel of the show
everything from you even bring melody
out you provide now I made your dog get
some - it's amazing well I brought you
know I brought a song back in the show
that I haven't done in a very long time
reverence probably something sure I
don't think I've done I'm not even sure
I've ever even done that live in concert
before
[Music]
[Music]
that I would have written just sitting
on myself at home so I wanted to
recreate that that whole vibe why hadn't
you done it before
first of all it's hard to sing you got
for you even for you I think would be
hard to sing for anyone no not I mean
I'm I'm not you know I'm not like the
world's most amazing singer but I think
even you know somebody with that a real
strong vocal prowess would find it a bit
challenging actually Prince recorded
that song
he changed the melody a night and of
course I didn't he and I had never
talked about it in person I I'd only
heard it just recently and I didn't know
whether he had changed the melody
because it was like a weird place to go
of course I could have done anything
with his voice but it is a hard one to
sing live but you taking it on taking on
the challenge
you got melody with you um this is a
Planet Hollywood we have seen when
Stefani Christina Aguilera have you
talked to any of those ladies about what
it was like for them to do a residency
here now that you're doing one well Gwen
Stefani I saw here was blown away by the
show I got a lot of really great ideas
about you know how the space works she
is a lovely lady I had met her years ago
at a halftime Super Bowl yeah and then
you know so we got reacquainted a bit up
on the voice and stuff like that I love
that you guys I'm picturing these
amazing divas all cycling through this
dressing room like you all show the same
dressing room right I think about that
when I'm in there you do what do I think
about yeah I think about the Backstreet
Boys and all all the people who have
gone through here I mean Jennifer did
anyone leave anything no I haven't found
anything yet I think I should start
looking at underneath like oh it's
realization
[Laughter]
I dunno of course your performance at
the AMA is blew everybody away
it was unbelievable and then post Malone
goes viral cuz he's dancing to your non
stop I know you want that collab to
happen have you guys talked about it
anymore at all no we haven't but I'll
make sure I catch on with him for sure
I'm to come out here can you come back
oh that would be awesome one news of
course this is totally the right place
everybody's here to party it was not a
beer cub
he's gonna kill ya we could do it in the
saloon we could do it in any set really
it would work ever anything works with
poseable um Diplo met you on our
platform at the AMAs obsessed over you
did you guys exchange numbers have you
talked to him about anything yeah we
have exchanged she's gonna come to the
show and when he does we'll all make
sure that we have a chance to maybe just
jam backstage you know and have a couple
of guitars back there I mean everybody
they were cutting to everyone singing
along with every word to all of your
songs Taylor Swift Liz oh I know you're
working on something maybe with Liz oh -
where's that at yeah Liz oh and Janelle
oh I wrote a song for the three of us so
we'll see how that comes together I'd
love that and did you hear from Taylor
like she just seemed like she was
watching her icon up on stage well I
thought I caught up with her backstage I
wanted to talk to her in person after
that show in jism you know congratulate
her because it was such a huge fantastic
night for her and so deserving I wanted
to just give her a hug in person and she
really she spoke about what was
important to her that night which was
cool yeah you know she's a great girl
and hard-working and I always love to
hear what she has to say by the way one
thing I also couldn't take my eyes off
was just how gorgeous you looked your
legs you look unbelievable everybody
told me I have to ask you some beauty
secrets while I'm here how do you look
so
amazing how does your skin look like
this like tell us please I exfoliate a
lot okay no III do excel me a lot okay
scrub voluminous and get rid of the
thigh and you know what I mean really
when it comes to beauty I feel most
beautiful when I take care of myself
you notice when I feel best whether I've
got makeup on or not I take more time to
pamper myself as I get older
I ride horses so that's probably you
know that's good for your legs how do
you take care of yourself when you're
doing something as intense as preparing
for and performing in a residency like
this you have to do a lot of fitness I
mean there's there's a lot of stairs in
this building
I'm just running through the running
through the aisles I love you down the
stairs everywhere but I really I I
relish that and I I know it's all part
of what I have to do when I'm out here
on stage I've got to be moving and
singing and and dealing you know
controlling my breathing I'm not a
dancer so it's not like I'm doing with
Jennifer Lopez does you know like
serious major dancing but weird if I
move around a lot I'm on the mover and
you know a lot of rock belting songs and
stuff so yeah you got to be there's a
level of fitness required
[Music]
you have one song that you do just love
to sing from all the hits if you had to
pick I didn't home I really like that
one a lot I enjoy singing it's still the
one any song that gets you really
emotional when you're out here
well Fretilin for always it's a really
great new experience to be able to do
that again I really love the song and
it's been so long so it's great
I'm really knit with that one so it's
it's emotionally really fresh and new
for me to just share with the live
audience what's go fill in that one
what's going through your mind when
you're singing that one I'm just
thinking I'm just getting into the mood
you know I'm swaying and I'm into this
beauty yeah like I'm genuinely into the
spirit of it and and lawston and I'm I'm
the fan of the song and I love the chord
changes and it's very much a Shania
singer/songwriter song very true to who
I am alone with the guitar I mentioned
JLo she's doing the next Super Bowl you
have done the Super Bowl what advice do
you have for her about taking on that
stage oh I mean I don't think I could
give her any advice she's I mean I
always watch her to learn from her she's
done it it's rather long she's well I
mean there's nothing that she hasn't
done I think that if I was to give her
any advice at all just have a really fun
great time and and get up there and
shake your booty like like you know how
to do so well is that a stage that
brings nerves and do you ever get
nervous anymore are you in it well the
thing about the Super Bowl is that it's
a very very very quick changeover so you
there's a there's it's quite pedantic in
a certain way you've got them you're
rushed out to the stage because they
gotta clear everything out get that sea
jet it's like bang bang bang bang bang
so if there's anything that is
nerve-racking it's the the production
crunch and it's really hard to get
settled before you're just like there
where I'm love so I think preparation is
everything last questions for you we are
actually we just this morning we're with
Gary Sinise and
no you just did that movie with him I
don't know if you know he does this we
were with him because he flies a plane
full of kids who are you know have had
parents who are veterans and he takes
him to Disney World and he takes these
kids to Disney World how great of a guy
is he he is so genuine and so giving
charitable he is very sincere about his
involvement with the program and he's he
talks about it all the time talked about
it on set he means it so I think he's
just he's a wonderful new friend I'm
very very happy to admit him I love that
and speaking of kids yours is yours 18
30 days 18 now have any musical genes
following in Mama's footsteps at all
yeah he's very passionate about making
music creating music composing music
he's he doesn't have this desire to be
on stage I'm not sure that he would ever
go in that direction he's following more
in the footsteps of creating the music
he loves to orchestrate music he's more
elaborate about what he does with
arrangements and all that sort of thing
but ya know he's oh my gosh you know
he's deep into it yeah yeah I know it is
awesome I'm very happy for him
all right Shania thank you for having us
here in the Twain town saloon we're
gonna play a little game with you called
sip or spill so I'm asking a question
and if you want to answer if you want to
spill great if you don't want to answer
that question you just take a little sip
here okay because you don't want to get
into it so up to you house they're all
basil let me take a sip now okay let's
cheers to the game in case I don't get
to do it during the game on take
advantage of it now we got it we got to
get a little liquid courage for the game
they're all based on your songs for man
I feel like a woman
yeah what most makes you feel like a
woman for all us you know what I'm gonna
drink to that tonight and see that
coming anything can happen in Vegas and
does what happens in between times
Wednesday in quaint town saloon yes yes
I promise all right
any man of yours better do what better
listen listen listen like the first time
yeah boss lady I love it of everyone
you've ever met in your career who did
not impress you much the first time ah
well now you can sip oh oh right I can
sip okay I'll do that
I mean if you had a good story I was
just trying to give you a lout there oh
no it doesn't impress me that I have not
still not met right there I mean come on
I know it is for your song about booths
of course most expensive boots you've
ever bought how much were they spill the
DS yeah I I don't trying to say to you
too much I spend more on crystals like
thousands on crystals
yeah crystals Oh for the costumes yeah
that go on the boots Oh on how much if
you had to guess how much is your most
expensive pair of boots worth well you
well I mean you know probably you could
spend anywhere between five to ten
thousand dollars on them on the right
pair of boots because I drilled of that
in my boots yeah some good boots Jenna
yeah know what I mean you know they last
these are boots that I can run in here
last question for you in honor of your
Negus residency yeah the craziest thing
Shania Twain has ever done in Vegas the
greatest thing I've ever done in Vegas
oh this is kind of crazy I mean I I
cooked I have to recut David
Copperfield's meat because he doesn't
like it to raw but it always good so
sometimes we eat late after the show
because he has a Late Show and so
midnight 1:00 in the morning I'll we'll
order some food in and and the meat
never comes cooking that's how I always
meet cooking yeah it's kind of crazy
right you're having late night meals
with David Copperfield
okay yeah no but the weird thing about
is that I have to cook his name like but
David it's steak yeah you like to see
like Steve and I have to reheat it all
the time yeah not really dude like we
cook it okay he needs to pay you I know
Jeff Jeff Shania
should I have thank you for playing
super spell cheers to your Vegas
resident
[Music]